leaders from across the gulf region have
signed a declaration
calling for solidarity and stability at
a summit aimed at resolving the
three-year dispute with qatar
representatives from gulf countries
including the emir of qatar have
gathered in the city of alula
it follows a move by saudi arabia to
open its air
sea and land borders to qatar in what's
seen as a big step towards resolving
an illegal blockade of the country
delegations from oman
bahrain the united arab emirates kuwait
and egypt
are also attending earlier qatar zemiya
sheikh tamim bin hamad al-thani was
greeted by the saudi crown prince
mohammed bin salman with
an embrace it marked one of the most
important moments in relations between
the gulf countries in recent years
our block has been built on the basis of
our shared roots and common traditions
with the aim of serving the interests of
our respective people
therefore we should all work together
towards achieving the goals on the basis
of which this block was formed
okay for more on this let's talk now to
our news correspondent
my colleague al jazeera's jamal l shail
jamal
who's been driving this well over the
past three years the consistent
uh push to resolve this has come out of
kuwait city there were initially mixed
messages coming
from washington however in the uh past
six to 12 months there seemed to be more
of a push from
the trump administration to resolve the
crisis which
many people pointed um towards trump's
policies for actually being behind the
divisions in the
first place the recent um let's say
uh efforts that managed to get this over
the finish line so to speak
uh did come following the visit of
senior white house adviser and
son-in-law of donald trump jared
kushner when he came to riyadh and doha
met with both
uh the emir of qatar sheikh mohammed
thani and the essential de facto ruler
of saudi arabia
uh crown prince mohammed bin salman and
that's when we saw a lot more movements
we saw the statements coming from
kuwait's foreign minister
uh as well as obviously uh this uh
uh lifting of the uh air land and sea
blockade by at least
saudi in the past 24 hours so that's
essentially been the main
uh pushes behind it but not lost on this
like i say is the role of both kuwait
and to a certain extent other countries
and that's why for example this summit
that's taking place on ola has actually
dubbed the sultan
and uh summit
in respect of the two late leaders of
our man in kuwait
both of whom had a role in either
reaching us to this bringing us to this
point or at least
uh defusing what was a very difficult
situation will there be lots of loose
ends that need to be
tied up and those loose ends may take
several weeks indeed several months
that's a very nice way of putting it
loose ends there are a lot of loose ends
and there are a lot of
differences the questions is do you
actually have to tie them up
and that's what people need to discuss
because countries do
have differing opinions they have
different policies at the crux of the
division peter wasn't the divisions or
the different
outlooks that these countries had in so
much as it was not being able to either
agree to disagree
or not being able to find the mechanism
where those differences
could be settled you had qatar on the
one hand
which was a lot more pluralistic in its
approach
to the arab world which was a lot more
inclusive in the way in which it wanted
to
not necessarily govern but at least
engage with
political forces in the middle east and
north africa region and then you had
the blockading countries which saw that
as an existential threat to their
either autocratic or kind of absolute
monarchies
and those divisions still remain whether
they will just agree to disagree as i
say or whether as you say they will try
and
hash them out on something we'll see but
just very quickly what's important to
note here
is that what's happened in el hola is a
declaration and not some sort of a
comprehensive deal
that has concessions and agreements
within it
okay we must leave it there for the
moment thanks very much jamal
mohammed val is on the qatar saudi
border with this
update from there there is some
activity around me you may not see it
behind me this is the border crossing
but around us there is a lot of activity
by the police
security however nobody has crossed
yet we've been here since the morning
nothing of that sort has happened we
have
asked the security personnel here they
told us they are waiting for
instructions but they said technically
the border is open
and we have seen them you know
into inside the booths behind me um
dusting off the desks and cameras and so
on so there is preparation going on but
there is no crossing yet
it's very crucial to see people crossing
here because this is the physical
aspect of this blockade on qatar this is
the only
land border that qatar has with the
outside world
and it is linking it with saudi arabia
it is a lifeline for many people who
have been
dealing in business and so on between
the two countries also for families
across the the across the region
remember the gulf region is a very
socially connected
area with tribes on both sides of the
border with families
here and there and they have been
separated that
that disruption in the social fabric has
been very painful
over the last three years and many
people are waiting for that situation to
end so
the expectation is that as the days go
by like tomorrow after tomorrow maybe in
three days from now
this border crossing will return to
normal
well sultan barakat is director at the
center for conflict and humanitarian
studies at the doha institute for
graduate studies
he says donald trump's involvement in
the crisis both allowed it to start but
also forced through a breakthrough
it was clear i think from the beginning
that mr trump
got everything confused and his
knowledge of the region at the time was
very limited
and he made statements that he and his
administration regretted later on
and and they reversed it uh they
reversed a lot of these issues
and this is one of the things that
really forced the hand of the saudis
to accept the the condition or in fact
the only response qatar has has given
right from the beginning that is we're
willing to talk but we are not going to
accept those
13 conditions we're willing to talk but
without any preconditions
that we we meet any of those uh totally
irrational uh
demands and in fa and as a result of it
of course uh
qatar did not just lay down and and take
the blockade they've done
a lot of effort to try and work round
the blockade they found alternative
routes to connect to the world to get
supplies and so on
but most importantly i think they stuck
to the law
and they pursued this with a great deal
of dignity
and recognition of the fact that states
are made by what the international law
makes
makes of them and to what degree they
respect that international law
so by the end of 2020 there were at
least
four or five cases that qatar has won
against dublicating countries all very
important landmark cases
to do with human rights world trade
organization
aviation case all of this
would have naturally the dublicate had
we just continued to this because
the the rest of the world recognized
that what
these blockading countries were doing
was absolutely illegal